Selfridges which is a high-end clothing
store in the UK is getting rid of the
men and women's clothing section and
they're going to be doing all
gender-neutral clothing yeah that's
right
we've got a quote from the Selfridges
spokesman the agender project is a
fashion exploration of the masculine the
feminine and the interplay found in
between it will take customers on a
journey where they can choose to shop
and dress without the limitations on
stereotypes now interestingly this isn't
just going to be about clothes it's also
going to have to do with the makeup
section and literally everything that
they're doing in the store I kind of
think this is cool like there's
something I have no problem with how
people dress and if a guy wants to dress
like girl and a girl is dressed like a
guy and every other combination you can
come up with I have no problem with it
but I feel like some people are going to
be pissed and say they see what you did
we let the gays get married and next
thing you know men are dressing like
women what do you think yeah I mean I
think it's just a big mass marketing
ploy you know they're like everyone step
in and you everyone can buy everything
and yeah I don't know it's it's crazy
right now especially with like the
Millennials and and they're very
entitled and they want to kind of choose
everything you know including their
gender which and that's fine you know
there's there's that's that's a whole
other topic but they live yeah it's kind
of all related to that I think you know
and I don't know I think it's ironic
because I feel like on one hand they're
like I'm trying to express myself and be
Who I am and this is what I'm gonna do
and I'm gonna be a boy and wear a skirt
or a girl and wear you know a tuxedo
whatever who cares but in the long run
they're just blending in they're like I
want to stand out so I can blend in
right now and whoever designed this was
like I'm gonna think outside the box to
make it look like it's outside the box
when it's really not outside right I
mean isn't that really though how
fashion in general always goes like I'm
old enough to remember when urban
outfitter was actually like cool it was
like truly like like that's where this
cool t-shirts were and now I go in there
and it's like oh this is just like what
the giant company is now trying to make
feel cool so really this is this is just
a big marketing situation right maybe I
think it's pretty awesome yeah I mean
yeah I mean you grow up and little girls
go to stores and the toy section is just
totally pink yeah little boys go to the
toy section
just trucks and you know action figures
and stuff and like we are raised to
think that we're supposed to fall within
a certain stereotype and that's total
[ __ ] yeah because now we're living
at a certain point you know in our
development in society where people are
open and they're able to express their
gender or sexuality however they feel or
however they personally want to identify
so I feel like a store like this is
great because you can go into it there's
no pressure for you to conform to
anything and you could just be yourself
and there's not like any weird
separation right and we're also not
forcing all stores to do this this is
just one store so if you don't like it
that's called choice and then you can go
shop somewhere else
but yeah this has been happening in
other things I live in West Hollywood
where the new thing now is
gender-neutral bathrooms like they're
not putting up separate men's and
women's bathrooms so to me when I see
that I always think that that actually
seems worse for the women in general
because guys pee everywhere I don't know
where the last time you gotta write
women's bathrooms are disgusting
I I don't know what are women peeing on
the floor oh yeah [ __ ] everywhere I
don't guess but oh now that game I don't
think there's you're in everywhere oh
man what's going on yes I always think
the women's bathroom you want and
there's like music playing oh no we're
gonna lie about this Mel's like perfume
yeah we must work what right yeah you
don't want to sit on the toilet because
you know we can't just stand up and pee
like guys you know we don't have that
luxury right we squat and then when that
happens sometimes certain women go
everywhere and they don't clean up after
them Yeah right and they just you know
or or there's like other personal
hygiene products left about oh yeah
it's not pretty so I would not go so
this actually getting the squatting is
causing splashing I mean there's all
kinds of stuff going on especially if
it's at a place where there's alcohol
involved like a bar or a club or just
forget it
yeah do they have any kind of like hooks
or something that you would be able to
balance yourself on to squat out like
you really have to just like you're like
you do a little hover thing yeah that's
crazy I'm actually like a ropers the
girls are just not skilled at this a row
you should invent this a row like if you
don't like a stripper pole yeah oh you
know like yeah like you're on the subway
so alright I guess my Theory's wrong
there
oh sure I also there's sometimes girls I
do anyway like you'd like to primp if
you're out and so if there's a guy who's
trying to get in the bathroom like
that's just so annoying or a buncha sand
but the lines would be shorter for us
this is true yeah Yeah right like even
when you go to a sporting game where
it's you generally I would say it's more
men you can get in and out of a male
bathroom really quick there's less women
and yet the line is like around the
state oh yeah by far um do you think we
would we lose anything by not having
specific generals I know that's what a
lot of people fear that if you do this
that somehow you know that that history
and evolution has taught us for the men
to be the hunter-gatherers and the women
to take care of the whole youth yeah go
yeah no I'm just
I don't like stereotypes I don't like
anyone feeling like they have to conform
to anything you should just be yourself
and that's it that should be the only
thing that you're thinking about not I
need to be more feminine or I need to be
more masculine just be how you want to
be